[музика]
сьогодні я чую ой тут цін на тесті за
розгін вчимося навпроти мене звуть липня я
системний адміністратор і ми не важливі
ваші всі проц і волоки
я вже п'ять руки в кільцевих були Китай
комунікацій компанії та power ти моя
робота над простих я мій контроль його
тягну у всіх комп'ютерах був доступ до
інтернету то баз даних у вас темний наш
центр нас можна протирати
у читачки роботі потреба вогню
зі сталевий адміністратор травня багата
значить ні просто нову вінду я габарити
та не компанії своя навчальний опочила
59 класами самому училищі ступор фінал
парад арку програмного забезпечення та
там не обумів основа праху цей початок
Саша до тієї потреби інформації віддали
сама
slide технології розвивається на фрімен
азар з доступною інформацією не громадою та
шкіри всього по три [ __ ] ви на вигляд але і
є закинути складу, чому ми
стикалися а б ви просто у видавити з
телевізор будинок самому я робота не активно
мені подібне те що таке моєї роботи
разом пройти інтернету мобільним аражем
колеса проти vectra b